foreign
[Music]
I've been interested in graph databases
and how their unique structure allows us
to view data in more flexible and
insightful ways that's why I'm excited
to have Ben here today from neo4j the
first data science platform to teach us
a bit more about graph databases and the
insights they help customers achieve Ben
thanks so much for joining us today can
you tell me a little bit about yourself
and about neo4j
uh sure thing so my name's Ben Lackey I
lead the cloud partner architecture team
here at neo4j that's working with our
Cloud Partners to build Integrations
that are better together with their
Technologies and Ours
neo4j itself is the leader in graph
databases so our database is designed to
represent natively not just data itself
but also the relationships between that
data this allows our customers to
achieve insights that aren't possible
with more traditional databases that
often represent data solely as rows and
columns
new insights of course means more
data-driven decisions which is super
important for businesses can you explain
to me what exactly is a graph database
and what are the different scenarios
that a graph database can be used for
sure thing so a graph database
represents its data as a graph and this
is a graph in the mathematical sense so
nodes connected by edges in neo4j we
call the edges relationships which isn't
the formal math term but sort of a more
friendly term
uh graph databases themselves can be
thought of as solving three types of
problems
so one of those problems uh relates to
Journey questions so you can think of
things like a lineage uh one very
obvious example in that is tracing
something through a supply chain so from
where it's say if we're talking about
food where it's farmed to where it's
wholesaled to where it's sold to your
dinner plate and we do many use cases
like that with shipping and logistics
companies
uh sort of a higher dimensional example
of that kind of use case is a complex
pattern matching so rather than just
following something along a line it's
also possible with the graph database to
make sense of whole webs of information
in the industry this is often referred
to as a Knowledge Graph one example here
would be one retailer we work with who
has hundreds of millions of skus and
they have loaded all those skus into the
knowledge graph so that it can power a
conversational agent and one of the
examples I really liked that they gave
us in a conversation was I as a customer
of that retailer can go to the
conversational agent and say hey does
milk have zinc in it the agent parses
that question
consults the knowledge graph looks up
milk looks up ingredients and then sees
that yes milk does have zinc in it and
can answer that question
so those are sort of two ways to use
graph databases the journeys and the
complex patterns one newer and more
emerging way is with graph algorithms so
once you have that complex graph built
up that web of information a knowledge
graph or maybe an operational graph it's
possible to apply these really
interesting algorithms on it to learn
things about the graph and that can
relate to neighbors within the graph it
can relate to centrality of nodes within
the graph or you can compute graph
embeddings that are then useful in other
systems thank you for explaining that
it's so interesting how many different
types of problems graph databases can
solve
where does neo4j fit in with Google
cloud and what problem did it solve for
us
right so Google cloud has a whole bunch
of different databases to solve all
sorts of different problems as part of
that portfolio if you need a graph
database neo4j is Google's answer and
this dates back to a program Google ran
in 2018 where Google went out to Market
and selected isvs independent software
vendors who are the best at whatever it
is in their space
for that graph space Google had selected
neo4j and ultimately this led to a tight
in console integration for neo4j where
you can go to the Google Cloud console
and deploy our software as a service
product or a DB with just a few clicks
it's so cool to have a partnership that
has been going on for a long time and
that Phil's product gaps so well and
really aligns to our customers needs can
you help us understand some of the
customer use cases that you've solved
using neo4j and Google Cloud
sure thing so uh fundamentally what
neo4j offers is a horizontal technology
and what's really neat about that is it
can see applications in all sorts of
different verticals uh one of the areas
we probably have the longest Heritage is
fraud detection in retail banking so
graphs allow you to detect Financial
transactions that shouldn't be going on
or fraudulent uh one very common thing
you see in fraud is something called a
fraud ring where somebody transfers
money from one account to another
account to another account and all those
accounts share information they should
not so the graph is really really good
at detecting that kind of thing
similarly we do a lot of work in supply
chain optimization uh one use case I
thought was really neat is with a cell
phone manufacturer and it's around
Logistics so if you need to deliver say
10 million cell phones by January 1st
those cell phones are made up of a whole
bunch of different components and all
those components might be sourced from
different suppliers those suppliers in
turn would have prices that they can
offer those components at delivery slas
and then quantities of those components
they can offer so you end up with this
very interesting graph optimization
problem of which suppliers should I
procure from in order to meet that
deadline of January 1st 10 million
phones while at the same time doing that
at the optimal price
one other area distinct from those two I
just mentioned where we do a lot of work
is in drug interactions with
pharmaceutical companies
so modeling different drugs and then
taking inputs from uh both tests and
trials on the outcomes of what those
drugs have done the graph really allows
you to uncover interactions that might
be missed in a more tabular approach wow
it's so interesting especially with the
supply chain interaction use case how
you can trace every single little detail
back and see all those relationships
that you had mentioned and really know
like this is going to be my best option
for my business so it kind of takes the
guesswork out which is really really
nice
so let's say I want to start using neo4j
I need some help with my supply chain on
Google Cloud how do I get started you
had mentioned an integration before yeah
there are a whole bunch of ways to get
started with neo4j
but probably the easiest fastest
simplest one to get going is fire up the
Google Cloud console and if you scroll
down towards the bottom there are
listings from a number of these
different isvs that Google has chosen to
partner with in this really tight-knit
way and of course neo4j is among those
you can simply click on that and then
click through the dialogues and in a few
minutes you'll have a neo4j aura
instance up and running and that aura
instance is fully managed so you don't
need to worry about
maintaining virtual machines or disks or
network or any of that all that
management is handled entirely for you
wow okay so you weren't kidding when you
said tightly integrated literally within
minutes you can have an instance with
neo4j that's super cool
so now let's talk a little bit about
what's under the hood I'm curious to
know like what's a typical architecture
that you see on Google Cloud neo4j
itself is kind of made up of three
components at its core is the graph
database and then there are these two
additional components Bloom of business
intelligence tool and graph data science
which is really useful for data
scientists
one of the most common patterns we see
is data coming from bigquery probably
one of the lowest touch easiest ways to
get started is simply to pull a CSV file
directly in from cloud storage that kind
of gives you an idea of how you can pull
the data into neo4j
once it's in neo4j there are all sorts
of really interesting things you can do
one of the use cases I'm probably most
excited about is building up a graph
within neo4j and then using the data
science component to compute something
called a graph embedding and a graph
embedding is a a tabular a vector
representation of the graph and why
that's really useful is that can then be
taken and used in other systems so one
really common model we're seeing is pull
data from bigquery into neo4j compute
embedding so we can leverage all that
structure and information about the
graph and then export that back out to
Google's cloud storage where vertex AI
can make use of that new data coming
from the graph to improve predictions
you're mentioning some customers build
knowledge graphs can you tell me a
little bit more about that and some
different approaches uh sure thing so
fundamentally we're seeing kind of two
different approaches to using neo4j and
a machine learning pipeline uh one is
this knowledge graph approach and in
that you have examples like the skew one
I mentioned earlier where retailer loads
hundreds of millions of skus and then
does lookups with a conversational agent
uh similarly there was another neat one
where an insurance company is using a
Google product called document AI to do
something called entity extraction from
claims data basically extracting who the
individuals and other entities in claims
data are and then putting that into the
knowledge graph and reasoning from that
so that's kind of one approach the
knowledge graph approach another
approach that we're seeing a lot of and
is more an emerging thing is you load
data from somewhere else some external
system bigquery is very common into
neo4j and then you compute graph
embeddings so the graph embeddings I
believe neo4j offers five different
algorithms to do that these are things
like Fast RP algorithms that came out of
Academia specifically to do this kind of
thing and in that scenario data comes
from some system data lands in neo4j
graph embedding is computed and then the
data is exported elsewhere where it's
made use of by some Downstream system
that isn't even related to neo4j
so we really see these two different
patterns either where we're an active
system of record as part of the data
pipeline or we're contributing uh some
expertise based on the algorithms we
offer
oh that's awesome and then in terms of
data science Bloom this is a kind of
visualization tool right like a bi
visualization tool can you talk about
how that's used yeah so kind of starting
at 30 000 feet you've got the graph
database which it's a database you know
it has a query language you can interact
with that you've got graph data science
which is these implementations of all
these graph algorithms 50 some odd
different algorithms for clustering
centrality embeddings things like that
and then finally what you just mentioned
there's a technology called Bloom and
this sits on top of the database and
it's a business intelligence tool and
while some of our users interact with
traditional business intelligence tools
you know things like looker Tableau
click spot fire stuff like that bloom
can be useful for for particular use
cases where you really want to take
advantage of the graph data and that's
because Bloom is really the only
business intelligence tool I know of
that was built from the ground up
focused squarely on graphs so it lets
you explore the graphs interactively
color nodes and edges different ways to
better visualize things and then one of
the newest features I was just added
probably a month ago or so you can
actually make calls in bloom into the
graph data science component so you can
say hey give me a centrality coloring on
all these nodes so I can see how Central
they are to the graph that's so cool
because it's efficient but it also gives
people the ability to take that
information they have and then visualize
it and get insights from it kind of in
in one go you mentioned you just
released this new feature what do some
future Tech technical enhancements to
the architecture look like or to you
know the product itself I mentioned
these different machine learning
workflows where we start with data we
put it in neo4j it feeds into Downstream
systems we have that workflow pretty
well put together
for training of a machine learning model
using the embeddings in vertex AI what
we haven't quite figured out today
is how to do the real-time scoring and
what the best architecture is for that
we have customers putting together
different approaches on their own but
we're trying to figure out what our best
practices are there so there are a lot
of really fascinating discussions going
on right now uh about what the best
embedding algorithm is to use and how we
would feed the data in from different
systems we're trying to figure that out
and I I think that's sort of indicative
of what's going on with the larger space
that we're very much at The Cutting Edge
here and uh there are a bunch of neat
problems to be solved and those have
really high value if you can
that's super cool uh is there anything
else super cool or interesting that
you'd like to share about neo4j well
kind of in that vein just the The
Cutting Edge thing this is a very
expensive from a computational
standpoint uh abstraction so only very
recently has it become computationally
tractable to do things like compute
centrality on large graphs and that kind
of thing we're at this very interesting
Tipping Point where the door has been
opened by advances in Silicon and now
we're we're figuring out how to take
advantage of what that silicon allows us
to do
it must be so interesting to be working
in this field in this company where
you're always at The Cutting Edge where
can people go to learn more about neo4j
well there are a bunch of online
resources and classes and things
probably the the best place to get
started is our graph Academy and that's
just neo4j.com slash one word graph
Academy
very nice so make sure to go check out
the graph Academy if you want to learn
more about neo4j and Ben thank you so
much for coming on here and teaching us
about neo4j and graph databases sure
thing thanks for having me after talking
to Ben today I'm even more excited than
I was before to continue to see the
future enhancements around graph
databases graphml and everything that
has to do with it and I hope you're
excited too thanks for watching and make
sure to like And subscribe if you like
this
[Music]